a night of celebration after days
of protests there he is
released on bail us mansonko addresses
the nation in this press conference by
his side
our leading figures of senegal's
opposition
the people are sending us politicians a
message
no matter our convictions or beliefs we
have a responsibility to unite
reassure and bring back politics to its
noble cause
representing the people several people
died and scores were injured after he
was arrested over
rape charges his supporters believe the
case is politically motivated
the presence of the military did not
deter demonstrators
nor did the tear gas nor the police
dressed in civilian clothes
wielding baseball bats restricting the
internet too did not stop the hashtag
free senegal from trending
hundreds if not thousands of people are
gathering here still defying the
security forces
who are firing tear gas there's a sense
among supporters of usmansanko that with
the end of his detention it's a victory
for them
and a reminder to the government that
they're accountable
not to big businesses and corporations
but to the people
demonstrators looted supermarkets
accusing president maki sal of failing
the country's poor by protecting big
business interests
after days of protests he finally
addressed the nation
realizing that the demonstrations were
not just about usmansanko
but about many senegalese feeling
disenfranchised
that a generation faced with so many
hardships
expresses its unhappiness is quite
understandable to me
at the same time let's avoid
participating in
anything that delays us in the quest for
a better future
when you run second business when you
attack the goods of others
you don't create jobs you destroy them
you don't reduce poverty you make it
worse
the president extended the coronavirus
curfew until midnight to allow small
shop owners longer business hours
but for many the protests are not just
about the
economic crisis or politics but about
defending senegal's long-standing
tradition of democracy and freedom
values protesters say are worth fighting
for
nicholas hawk al jazeera at dakar